welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for Marvel Studios I am Groot
season two another round of shorts
coming September 6th and with cameos
from The Watcher and Steve Rogers in a
way the lore of the Guardians of the
Galaxy continues to deepen so let's
break down this trailer frame by frame
to translate all the alien text and
point out some other interesting details
you might have missed let's get started
I am Groot
all right we start with Groot in his
baby Groot age as these shorts are set
between Guardians of the Galaxy vol 1
and volume 2 in the MCU timeline Groot
plays with a Captain America Steve
Rogers action figure and a can of
something first having the fight and
then having them kiss this would be
before a Groot would actually meet Steve
Rogers in Avengers Infinity War oh by
the way this is a friend of mine free
I am Steve Rogers now this action figure
looks like an Avengers endgame era of
Captain America so I don't know what to
make of it but in 2014 Steve Rogers was
forced to turn against Shield after it
was revealed to have been corrupted by
Hydra but it does seem like the
Guardians and the ravagers might have
had some kind of supply lines to get
Earth's stuff like this before the
events of Avengers Infinity War so maybe
the tales of the Avengers actions could
have made it out to the ravagers and the
Guardians here in space we also don't
know of any actual action figures in the
MCU that were made of Steve Rogers but
he was a pretty popular guy in the 1940s
and had plenty of other merch made of
him group could be reenacting the fight
in Bromance between Steve and Bucky
Barnes or between Stephen Hawk because
it is a big thick green can or this
could all just be a meta Joe and Groot
is kind of reenacting caps duel with
Thanos and end game and then weirdly
having them kiss he does do a higher
voice for the can though so with that
green label maybe he's shipping Steve
Rogers with Gamora I'm probably
overthinking all this let's move on
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
okay so Groot hurries out to the window
and this is a pretty massive ship I'm
thinking it's a ravager ship the
eclector which some of the shorts and
season one were set on Groot sees this
ice cream truck ship this pink neon sign
it's in a language I'm not exactly sure
which it is but based on my ability to
just spend too much time translating
this and doing some simple substitution
decoding the second and the fourth
letter are the same ones and the third
and the six letters are the same ones
those are the ones that look like equal
signs so I'm thinking the second and the
fourth are C's and the third and the
sixth are ease because obviously This
spells out ice cream so from that of
this language we now have the a the C
the E the I the m and the R so
essentially what I'm doing here folks is
the same kind of substitution code that
we use to figure out the full alphabet
of the Riddler's code in the 2022 the
Batman movie now you'll notice that the
struck plays the typical ice cream truck
music Scott Joplin's the Entertainer
now a lot of the specific items are in
the Builder machine code that we've seen
in the I am Groot shorts in the past
this one reads flow cubes and then there
are a few more that are just pretty
tough to make out because they're on LED
screens they just all seem kind of
blurry but then we get a quick shot of
an ice cream cone that I'm pretty sure
is based on Howard the Duck looks just
like him with the ice cream melting so
that it looks like he's frowning there's
a yellow bag with a blue vasaki this is
a species blurp is from volume three but
we actually saw a hairless fasaki all
the way back in volume one when it was
fighting in that fighting pit in nowhere
and the text on this screen is the same
language as the ice cream sign still
trying to figure out what the exact
words are in pink but in yellow along
the banner in the bottom it reads for
free Groot wants this ice cream so much
he breathes condensation on the glass
and he wipes it to form a heart then he
pulls out his pockets showing just empty
root strands I like how Groot formed in
his Anatomy these little pockets where
he could store stuff probably learning
from the clothes of the other Guardians
like rocket and Peter Quill and thinking
to himself that must be part of their
bodies let's move on
[Music]
okay in this section group Pilots a
smaller craft and you can see reflection
as goggles is the ice cream truck so
he's gonna be chasing this thing down
then we get a shot at the Milano
piloting past the Watcher uwatu voiced
by Jeffrey Wright in the what if series
what if being the MCU animated series
that we all thought we would be getting
before I am Groot season two but here we
are the big part of that might just be
the fact that they only really need Vin
Diesel just to say I am Groot whereas
for what if they need a ton of voice
actors now obviously I am Groot is all
animated but so far it's only really
shown MCU characters and settings and
other ships that in live action would
have been rendered with 3D animation
anyway so technically it could also be
live action even though it's not I know
it's animated it's just as animated as
many parts of MCU movies and shows are
so we could look at this as another
live-action appearance of The Watcher at
least his outline cast Among the Stars
like that our first sight into the
Watchers were in Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 2 when they were chatting with Stan
Lee also showed a statue of The Watcher
in The Eternity chamber we'll talk about
the Watcher a bit more later at the end
of this video for most things there's
the kids version and the grown-up
version diapers become underwear
playdates become grabbing coffee and
cereal becomes magic spoon magic spoon
is cereal reinvented it's the same great
taste that you remember but upgraded
with grown-up ingredients there's
nothing artificial it's high protein
keto friendly gluten-free grain free soy
free wheat free and naturally flavored
magic spoon cereal has zero grams of
sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein 4 to 5
net grams of carbs in each serving and
only 140 calories per serving if you're
on the go and need a cereal bar instead
each magic spoon cereal bar has one gram
of sugar 10 grams of protein 4 net grams
of carbs and only 130 calories per bar
and now you can build your own variety
box with any of magic spoon's best
flavors you can choose from the
best-selling cocoa fruity frosted and
peanut butter and maple waffle flavors
I'm currently eating a bowl of frosted
and you can mix with those best sellers
other awesome flavors including Honey
Nut blueberry muffin birthday cake and
cinnamon roll once cereal bars in your
variety box add cookies and cream or
cocoa peanut butter it's your choice
magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's packed with a 100 happiness
guarantee if you don't like it for any
reason they'll refund your money no
questions asked and if you're in Canada
or the UK magic spoon will ship there
too click the link below or scan the QR
code on the screen and use the code new
rockstars for five dollars off or go to
magicspoon.com new rockstars to save
five dollars off your order today but
here we see Groot trying to make some
coffee sweeter and sweeter and sweeter
with some marshmallows and then this
purple bottle that has skrull writing on
it they flip it right side up it
translates to cream and along the top
they're in smaller text is the word
purple so purple cream obviously one of
the shorts will be this snow planet
where Groot builds a snowman equipped
with deadly machine parts start simple
with just a harmonica in the mouth and
knobs for eyes but then over time it has
multiple arms with claws and Buzz saws
and Laser cannons from the shoulders
heading through the ice but also notice
how Groot wrapped this in Christmas
lights which might be part of the tree
decorations that rocket later used to
decorate young adult Groot swell group
in the holiday special there's also
gonna be an episode where Groot has
removed some purple gem from some type
of ancient ruins leading to this
artifacts viewing lava I like the fact
that it's purple because it reminds us
of Peter Quill taking the purple Power
Stone That Was Then encased in the orb
from the temple in Morag in volume 1.
we're also gonna get an episode where
group be friends and adorable pink bird
because it looks like every season has
to have group interacting with these
adorable animals it's also gonna involve
a Chase Through the Jungle with several
of these birds one of them in a fanny
pack with the same color scheme as
Milano okay on to the final clip hmm
[Music]
okay groups beside this box with all
these spare parts limbs with a shoe at
the end and one of these looks like
borker's eye that's the eye rocket one
at a volume one and Groot found on the
ravager ship in volume two but Groot
puts on this orange nose and it is an
actual nose apparently gives Groot a
sense of smell for the first time and
Groot suddenly realized how bad he
stinks he sprays his face with a
dangerous aerosol deodorant and on that
can you can see more machine Builder
code that translates to kill sge and
then Ires something and then the Bottom
clean and I would thank Erica was super
Translating that one so really the
question here is how essential are the I
am Groot shorts to watch from the
perspective of a Marvel completionist
well I would say in terms of narrative
they really are just meant to be fun and
they are super fun and they're super
short there's no reason not to watch
them but the reason I like to break them
down is they contain all these
interesting Easter eggs production
design details and just crazy other
around the Galaxy that is Canon to the
MCU that I think we really need to talk
about these shorts just give us a deeper
context of how connected the Guardians
of the Galaxy are where to Earth and
other planets before the events of
infinity War and what else might be out
there in the MCU also what Groot and
Rocket's backstory really was because
not too long ago James Gunn Finally
Revealed his intended origin story for
rock and Groot through that figure named
to be a slark that was on groot's
booking screen on xandar in volume 1.
how he was this eccentric zookeeper that
they were imprisoned with in a well and
how they used his robotic lower half to
build a machine gun to fire their way
out of it and that was really what
started their interest in prosthetic
Limbs and turning them into weapons but
the Watcher now it seems like the
Watcher's taken a much greater interest
in Groot in particular from this part of
his life meaning Groot it looks like
it's gonna play a larger role in the
Multiverse events that lay ahead like
the next season of what if and perhaps
even Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars root
is an interesting character as a flora
Colossus whose Anatomy came back in
secret Invasion and the fact that he
evolved into this King Groot this Alpha
group form the Guardians 3 post-credits
scene just leaves far more Mysteries to
what exactly he is and why he grows the
way he does and I think that story could
be told in secret Wars and I think
seeing the Watcher like this is just
another step toward a live-action
Jeffrey Wright Watcher which would just
be awesome hey and you know what it's
going to be nice to have some MCU
content to ease our appetites before
Loki Returns on October 6th please
subscribe to all three channels in the
new rockstars Network you can follow me
on all social platforms at eavos follow
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign